now i will give credit to pbs washington
post uh fox abc they're running raw live
streams online of this and many many
people are watching also give a shout
out to rocata law because they've been
doing these massive legal analysis live
streams of the trial which have been
fantastic
and it is the mainstream media that has
now begun broadcasting this stuff but i
still don't think we're getting a fair
trial
i want to say a few things
the first i want to highlight this story
from tech spot
kyle rittenhouse defense claims apple's
ai manipulates footage when using pinch
to zoom this is big today the
prosecutors were able to admit
false evidence into the into the trial
because the defense wasn't smart enough
to explain to the judge who also didn't
understand the tech
why the images being presented were not
real evidence from the night in question
and i'll point out
the judge his phone rings god bless the
usa plays progressives begin demanding a
mistrial not with prejudice a mistrial
because they want a new judge
i believe the judge's love for this
country has resulted in a bias in favor
of the ideological left and is a
weakness suffered by libertarians and
moderates and conservatives that we keep
saying we will uphold our values for
those seeking to destroy them
the other day jack murphy asked me if i
thought uh based on that argument the
911 hijackers should get a fair trial
and i said of course and i think an
easier way to explain this is when you
have a prosecutor and a defense who both
believe in the values of innocent until
proven guilty we're good but when the
prosecution believes in power by any
means necessary to destroy our values
the judge should not tolerate that
because they're seeking to obs
subvert our our our law and order
which brings me to what happened in this
in today's case so here's the story
right the defense basically said and i
made fun of them for this and i take it
back i apologize for mocking them he
said
you know the apple uses a 3d ai
logarithm to to create an image and i'm
like
he doesn't know what he's talking about
now i do think i was right to be
critical of them because their inability
to articulate the problem resulted in
the prosecution being able to actually
admit this evidence albeit in a limited
structure
i want to explain something very simple
to people optical zoom
is when a lens on a camera
changes the focal point and you can see
further and further away optical zoom is
legitimate zoom in fact when the defense
argued that
pinch to zoom digital enhancement isn't
is an ai they weren't they weren't wrong
they articulated articul articulated
poorly the judge ordered the prosecution
to bring in an expert to testify
that this evidence is legitimate the
expert who came in said it is not
zooming when you enlarge it is different
the problem was the defense did not know
how to say very simply to the judge
in their
a pinch to zoom image is an artificially
created image that does not represent
the knight in question it is effectively
a computer rendering creating
information that did not originate from
the original knight in question it's
that simple
let me give you a breakdown from a
random reddit user because there's a
thread about this on r technology i do
think this is relevant
this reddit user says i have no dog in
this fight but i'm a hobbyist computer
vision enthusiast this is very simple
and very important zooming in on images
makes them bigger not clearer to make
them clearer you have to add information
that wasn't there before interpolation
there are many ways to add information
and that information added will change
depending on what method is used that
added information absolutely can be
misleading
and it is not necessarily indicative of
reality the computer is essentially
trying to guess what pixels would fit in
the gaps and making a guess that is an
accurate reflection of reality is not a
trivial problem many algorithms are only
designed to look good and be fast the
onus is on the prosecution to justify
the accuracy of the information they
added to the evidence when they used
apple's zoom method if they can't do
that then they need to present the video
with no added information
i could not believe when i watched this
this testimony because the defense was
like no no no when we when we enhance
this there's new pixels right and the
expert goes yes he goes and what color
are they and he goes similar colors but
you don't know what colors are supposed
to be there and he goes i'm not an
expert on how the algorithm works and
i'm like defense please stop talking
about pixels and colors that is neither
here nor there it's quite simple
here's what i would ask of the expert
the enhanced image you provided us it is
is it 100
accurate information
that that was originating from the night
in question and his answer would be
no
so my question then is
the image you are presenting is not an
image from the night in question
no it has added information that came
from somewhere else where did it come
from my computer lab a week ago
then i would say to the judge this image
is not of the night in question
therefore should not be evidence because
it doesn't come from the night in
question they couldn't just say that in
10 seconds he was trying to argue about
pixels and colors and is it purple
should it be purple why shouldn't it be
purple and i'm like what are you telling
people and the judge was confused and
the prosecutor goes your honor they're
trying to take advantage of your your
lack of your ignorance with all due
respect of technology to pull a fast one
on you and make you not understand this
is legitimate evidence
it's simple the photo admitted into
evidence is not a photo of august 25th
2020
period the prosecution is cheating
they're lying and they're getting away
with it why because the judge is a good
guy because the judge believes
that
you know we have to have this system
even after the judge has said you are
not acting in good faith he's
unbelievable
he said that i don't believe you i'm
acting in a good faith like i don't
believe you when you when you say that
i i had a tweet last year where i said
that the kyle rittenhouse case convinced
me to vote for donald trump
donald trump pinned that tweet to his
account the only pinned tweet effective
uh he he liked it sorry he he liked it
which meant if you go to his account and
click likes only my tweet was there my
thread explaining what's going on with
kyle rittenhouse where i basically
explained the democrats the
establishment corporate press have lied
to such a degree i fear for for my
future
when they can accuse you falsely of a
crime and then destroy your life over it
and that we need active resistance to
this even if it means voting for donald
trump
the media
pushing their lies took that and tried
to falsely represent what i was saying
and what i was supporting and started
claiming that people like me and
rittenhouse were supporting overt white
supremacists who are hunting down black
people
that is the epitome of evil
and the prosecutor in this case does not
believe in the constitution he's already
violated on more than one occasion today
he was questioning drew hernandez we've
had on the show who was a direct fact
witness who watched this happen and said
you retained the lawyer therefore you're
biased
and the judge snapped at him what's the
relevance here
the judge by now should realize the
prosecutor is not playing by the rules
and seeks only to gain power
these people are evil
and i think it's as if we keep ignoring
the fact these people
their world view is comprised of
destruction they don't want to make the
world a better place right they don't
want justice they want to watch the
world burn and they want to steal while
they do it's too simplistic
it's too much like cobra commander
there's no they're not saying that
they're evil is kind of vague because
it's different different strokes for
different folks they're going to call
you evil it's just vague like i don't
think his intention is to destroy
everything i think he he believes he's
doing good but they're he's going about
it poorly i think you are too naive
we just we we we're going to get into
this in a second but let me just stress
that hank newsome of black lives matter
said we will riot and there will be
bloodshed i think you try and bring
police back in to stop crime i think
your t-shirt is what's explaining the
whole thing and i tweeted a couple hours
ago there is a direct parallel i think
and a huge correlation between the kyle
rittenhouse trial between russia gate
between what i deal with in the climate
change stuff ukraine gate your agenda is
more important than facts and more
important than ethics more important
than laws the constitution procedures
your agenda is x and i have to uphold
this agenda and so if i have to go
through this process i don't care if
evidence says there's no climate change
i don't care if evidence says donald
trump didn't have european hookers peon
as like i don't care any of that stuff i
need this result i need this to be the
result so all this other stuff you're
talking about the niceties of procedural
that just is in my way i will dismiss
that absolutely effortlessly that's what
the gulag is they're doing right that's
all that because i need this conclusion
let me let me actually let's let's let's
make a cultural uh analogy here you know
i love doing that ian are zombies evil
according to dungeons and dragons yes
[Laughter]
i would actually say it's fair to say
zombies aren't evil i think that's a
fair they're mindless yeah they're
mindless neutrons so when you have a
bunch of people who are mindless
they're destroying they're destructive
they are used i don't think the
run-of-the-mill anti-fun black lives
matter extremist rioter there are evil i
think there many of them are criminals
not all of them but many of them i'm not
with the writers not protesters
uh it's like what we saw in kenosha they
have passed domestic abuse things they
abused children in extreme ways and it's
because these are the dregs of society
who are angry and dejected and uh and
they're and they're actively criminals
or sometimes they're mentally unwell and
they commit this violence i don't think
they're evil however
is the necromancer evil
almost undoubtedly yes and the zombie
lord would be evil
the one controlling the zombies yes yes
so the lich king
who knows he is plaguing people with a
zombie virus and rot and raising corpses
from the dead for the purpose of gaining
power is evil so when you look at ada
banger he is not a zombie the zombies
are the rioters no he's a necromancer
yeah
no no i don't know what you nerds are
talking about but i think that really
evil guy is the mainstream media and big
tech social media that are also spinning
the webs here because when you look at
the larger institutions it's not just
some crazy people on twitter there's
another element here of social media
interrupting injecting and making sure
that only one voice is heard here that
one delusion mindset it's spread here
and that of course is the mainstream
corporate authoritative quote
authoritative voices that get promoted
here what what do those voices do well
they either obfuscate or promote
violence and when you look at it from
that kind of aspect when you see the
real life harm that happened to this
country a year and a half ago the last
summer you see how many people died you
saw how many people lost their
businesses you saw entire cities go up
in flames and the mainstream media
cheered it on said it was mostly
peaceful the main the social media that
promoted all of these things helped
people organize for them when you look
at it from that perspective
yeah kamala harris literally the most
unpopular vice president ever in
american history more unpopular than
dick cheney who shot his friend in the
face
emmanuel macron the rott's child banker
doesn't even want to kiss her and he
kisses everybody
why are you lowering my mic for lydia
i'm watching you all right i gotta i
gotta say it again
dick cheney literally shot
the top establishment institutions the
power that be controlled by of course a
lot of the corporate billionaire class
literally having their narrative
literally having their agenda and their
agenda is chaos order out of chaos
divide and conquer it's exactly what's
happening right now it's textbook it's
what's happened before it happened with
9 11 it happened with the war on drugs
the war on terror now we have a war on
covet now we're gonna have a war on
equity
all of this is gonna repeat the same way
until we wake up and see the larger con
game being played against us the west
virginia democrat did twitter ever
say his he was
sharing this information makes it up you
know be curious to see if your millions
of followers if anyone has ever seen a
tweet that was about the from the left
of the written house case that that
twitter said this is misinformation i
mean i know the answer to that but it's
just it's it's fascinating isn't it he
took a still
frame from a video where kyle
rittenhouse was being attacked and then
posted it and maybe he didn't
make this information but he posted it
and i'm not gonna assume anyone else
made it up he posted it and it said that
rittenhouse was attacking rosenbaum
these people don't look for evidence
the zombies
you can't reason with a zombie
you look at the moderates the
intellectual dark web the politically
homeless and the conservatives and for
some reason they're all willing to
actually watch videos yeah and look at
the evidence the funny thing about all
of them is that the politicians who who
engage in this because i know when he
was a
candidate for president biden tweeted
about written house i know all the
members of the squad did every
politician chimed in they all used the
white supremacy thing
it is zombie-esque that they all echoed
the same talking point it is amazing
though that they all had to immediately
go to race because they know that's what
gets everyone excited because that has
nothing to do with race it's white
people shooting and getting shot at by
white people
it was in the midst of of of black lives
matter but but i mean everything is now
in the midst of black lives matter this
is in the midst of black lives matter
they rule the country i don't i don't i
don't think the race thing is going to
play up for much longer i think it's
been it's been breaking down because
people don't understand it anymore yeah
you know initially everybody was averse
to racism like we all we all
pour it it's bad but now it's to the
point where you know even bill maher is
like what are you talking about like
like a the the uh a black woman
lieutenant governor is a white
supremacist sincere is the black face of
white supremacy in virginia thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time